what was your reaction when rosman won
the golden globe oh my god
my reaction over here was crazy i'm
gonna take an
extra second to show you because i have
these really funny photos
so first of all i was really drunk when
this happened
i was like out and about and i was like
i'm not gonna worry if we win or we lose
i'm just like excited that this is
happening
because for me her winning is me winning
because it's like my pride wife
like i'm like oh my wife she's so
beautiful she's so talented
so anyway my stylist styles julie
gardner and she
called me in the middle of the night
because it's pretty late and roseman was
like 4 a.m with her
she's like rosa man just won and i
remember
falling to the floor and i took a
picture of myself and that's what i'm
trying to find as we speak
oh i hope i can find it and i facetimed
her and i'm like drunk on the floor just
like
rolling and i just cried we both cried
together
i think that we did i care a lot being a
very small independent movie we didn't
have backup that we have
right now here we are so you can see i'm
really
excited and i'm crying that's rising and
crying but that
that's me crying and i kept and i just
kept on rolling we're so
look at that wifey i'm so excited get
that face on my
but it was a small movie and seeing you
know the ripple effect and i was just so
proud of her she worked so hard she
deserved every single moment of it
because i've never seen a dedication the
way she is she's so involved she's so
hands-on
and again no small role when at the time
this movie came around i dropped out of
other two movies to do this because i
felt very
confident that this was the right choice
and this was the movie and the role that
i needed to do it helped me get out of
like the stigma and stereotype of like a
bombshell or like a
sexy latina it was just like a cool edgy
character that had a lot of heart and a
lot of love
and the effect that it has had thanks to
like the platforms and netflix has been
crazy so
i'm very grateful
you